you know and welcome to this week's
edition of Android has office hours so
coming to you live from London my name
is Nick butcher and i'm joined by
Richard Heinberg my god and as usual
this is your chance to ask us the
Android developer relations and google
TV relations any Android GT v8 open
question as usual this is not a forum
for announcing new products or
commenting on launch date so forth so
unfortunately will not be able to
comment on those things but yeah any any
questions or discussions around and
Rodger Berman this is earned this is the
place yes Carlos from Madrid that was
like I was close free free end to their
to the 30 to this with a moderator
question ask me something that we're not
going to sorry about that we have a few
usual suspects lied in a hangout so I
see Hugo you'll see and is that tile
yeah yeah that's me got two people on
phones this week that's what happens
when it gets close to Christmas how you
doing guys I'm good I'm not on the phone
I'm on their computer okay any exciting
Android developer news you've already
discuss I think we just have a yeah
absolutely are the Play Store team some
of which are based out of London just
pop their heads through the curtain here
to say that they just flip the switch
press the button and launched the
feature that is expansion files on the
new Google Play Developer console whoa
so that's why something last point the
last one more ticket lottery castle so
yes and hopefully a lot see you use the
new and improved developer site you
should hopefully be enjoying its you
know better organization and responsive
design and all this good stuff on the
new website and so yeah slowly moving
all the features from the old site
interview at better design I know it
support expansion I held also something
about YouTube right YouTube API new i
pair something like that I had this
thing excellent features more brother is
a theory there's a new version of the
YouTube API a didn't get to check it out
it just wanted to know if you know
something about
it was announced at Google i/o no good
thing it is they each year baby I think
yeah you too treecko ya you can get to
the YouTube developer office hours at
developers.google.com /live but yeah the
new YouTube in vapi is that developers
doctor will come for sat youtube I
haven't looked into the tour yet so if
anybody has any more information on what
the YouTube data API v3 is um excellent
cool cool alright so Jenny anyone like
the room have any questions or should we
jump right on into that moderator I had
a quick question about something simple
but I didn't find it out too when I use
their places on a button on my F I want
to lock the device you know to send it
to lock screen okay and then find
exactly how do i do it i held something
with administrative permissions or
something like that i don't know ya know
this ice is part of the mines i thought
the new minister so how do i go about it
to get a the device to go to lock screen
once let's say plus is a button in my
app I seen it on the normal searches on
sack of flour google and stuff yeah i
tried a few sample codes that you know
people left but none of them seem to do
the job i think in the past you could
set the writers 20 it would love to let
sure if that's official or no I think
that's working over is this a question
from tower by any chance he got said
this and then invoke it because it's
like you got manager but people are
saying some reason what I don't know
this is why we asked people to please
put their questions in the Wainwright
first your app cannot stop anyone from
pressing homogeneous reversible now you
can programmatically local screen with
the screen locker key guard manager
system service activity keyguard service
have you tried that one top and
no I miss that one on stuck is it on
stack overflow is the number one answer
on stack overflow when I searched for
rock Android device I look for the
keyguard manager and the disabled
keyguard permission okay so I'll go and
look at that and see where that leads me
I've got the nexus 10 they want
illuminating my face give me something
no no yeah I got one of my cell phone so
it's pretty late in my face you know
somebody's a crayon I think it's all so
many Gregory hey if the nexus 10 cover
them yeah we have a look here boy a few
new faces here as well we have Giuseppe
ciao Giuseppe oh and Marie I think this
is the first time you've ever join us
Marie there's a very few places here as
well we have two separate charges have
been real woman please Bree yes yonce
three more relatable creation as well as
a great yes Lacey you to target the
sound is really big oh yeah you're
watching us twice so Maurice on an
infinite loop there emotionally to close
the YouTube tab Marie and then hopefully
you're learning every once be the
Hangout all right oh she's knocked out
oh ok and he lets you gotta get Andrew
Kelly down here hello Clement oh there
is no now ok Dave no it wasn't the
YouTube it was a I have a special
microphone
wrong with you good it's Christmas we're
having our meat much grief e happening
hello Nick enemy Italy okay nice
Christmas time and thank you for all you
yes just I want to say just hello hello
I wish I could take em lam for you hey
survive on you hoodie I have android in
my pocket meet you rich is a large and
he goes oh yeah are you Richard I were
doing very well thank you marie and what
are you doing in holiday I really meant
to finish my a pop I know there's only
one screen left I'm just watching to
your feedback I know it's getting very
close now but I don't get a chance to
work on it I was buying Christmas
presents instead that's to be okay
promise this Christmas you're going to
finish or updates reality absolutely and
usually have a lot of the entire
experience seven see just how easy it is
that I'm a boost your holo UI epic right
I'm a question when when do is plan to
start in 2013 um your Android design in
action show on the first generally go of
seconds that's a good point good
question show that even decided yet
Tuesday in 2013 o hara ball and 107
sounds good year to severe she's already
tried to t know best call me Jojo
although we will speak to adamant Roman
and we'll put something on them we'll
announce something that would be nice
maybe I can prepare something
Oh lovely plans and that's why all goes
today and you're invited to join us in
Berlin next year fine special plan and
maybe I see you in January I got a mail
from your color oh ok all secrets to us
but what smooth out your artwork up
around the office now to make you feel
very much time we probably have more of
your artwork up in our office than you
have in your own house that pic entry ok
I don't want to interrupt your developer
office hours I know am I designer I have
to leave yeah discussion and yeah I just
want to say hello and have a nice
Christmas time and see you soon thank
you very much thanks to you yeah Nigeria
thank you for all your word 50 Dodgers
but ah ok so Clemens has asked us a
question in the chat window which
maximally important read the data
concerning enacted in thief if this is
relevant here because it's a Google
circuit city M it is if you have time at
some point so much ok question already
actually ok so I'll come in Cicero
question either pop the question has
come through in the G+ base runner and
also didn't need you know get the t
formation let's give the cheapest place
that's see when Jess Peter says cool
sweater rich wake you get 10 got this
last year unfortunately I used to it one
week last year and now it's back in
service for the week before Christmas
this year um I know I know I'm phylogeny
go we're never on sale you just have to
get one waited and next up and Alex I
think he asked the same question in the
moderator for us can I share a secondary
screen there between multiple devices
for example if I will connect to nexus 4
using some miracles wireless adapter to
the same TV and
relationship always wanted app to want
to see the same layout that can be
controlled from both Nexus fours as I
have two phones so the answer is no
basically the way that the miracle
standard worked as if it's a Wi-Fi
direct connection between one device and
the adapter so I can't to start with see
any way that you could have two devices
correcting to the depth at any one time
and then the way that the presentation
API works and the second screen API on
Android is it's very much one layout one
kind of look it's almost like a dialogue
really its own context and so on and
it's actually attached and owned by 11
application on the phone so it's not
like you can even background the
application still have something
on-screen it's very much like the pair
between what's on screen and what's on
the device so you'd have to use some
kind of intermediary think so maybe one
device of your house and the other folk
connect to the other phone so you
probably do what I direct answer to the
time for some other like socket
connection or Bluetooth or something
like that to talk between phones
themselves and one of the phones would
have to be the master controlling what's
on the TV display let's see any way I
can see they are doing that or you could
then perhaps you something like GTD
where GTV new google TV itself could be
the master and then both phones talking
to that yes we've got the only map
protocol so that would be able to handle
the multiple devices connect to the one
google TV twice and then yeah because
it's got its own application can deal
with however you want to do it i have
certain people taking from here priority
other devices yet so yeah this couple
options on the Google TV side yeah I
hopefully there's a few options for you
exhibition hikes and so it has cummins
how his question now yes ok so what I
missed in v3 is there is actually no way
at least documented to check surface is
all it's available on not so I'm
assuming this is checking that the
in-app billing version v3 is available
no you can check them you know what a
floor zones I then implemented little
method which checks to the condo Android
opening of the later in-app billing
service top find service intent but I
don't actually know if that would
totally works ask him myself why that
virtue is missing
will it be can second some that not
quite open so how you go around checking
the space is filling available yeah
there is a gateway 3 yeah there's a call
for is billing available which will
check it's the 13 all of our samples do
right yeah yeah better you have to bind
first you bind to the service and then
you check you ask the service of
Billings available and if the bind to
the service fails then assume ur service
isn't there maybe he wants to know if
there's a way of checking whether the
service is going to be there before but
then that would be filtered out based on
the Play Store and the thing- these
threes backwards compatible though all
right okay okay remember questions come
up in the gfs read while I'm gonna stick
around for a link and he Dan Williams
asks he has recently optimizes
application for tablet devices how does
Google Play determine when an app is
optimized tablets ie how to make it
visible to the tablet users so the
answer is your manifest basically tells
Google Play what your which screens your
applications have boards and that's it
really so you don't need to do any extra
steps it's not like some other stores
out there where you have to opt in and
take a box or something like that and
the you know you are using the support
screens manifest if you love your and
within your application tells Google
Play what twice iskcon converting that's
done but good job via one thing you will
hopefully see is that we are doing where
applications which run better and
optimized for tablets will should
hopefully start ranking better on tablet
devices when it's actually in the place
balls i hope you'll see that there's
nothing you have to do that's just us
tweaking our
our internal algorithm can't share the
details of just a place are now looking
at the smallest width qualifier we're
still at the support screen so the
filtering year is not using the smallest
bit of just yet it's so using support
screen but at some point of future
hopefully will be will be moving to them
no have you traveled nope sorry okay
refresh right should we take it if there
any any live questions in the ring can I
ask you a question please hello um I was
a reading this morning news about the
new encryption in a jelly bean okay
about the APK in the application
encryption yeah can anyone suggest that
i could the documentation somewhere to
read and understand well how to use this
a new feature in the jelly bean to
encrypt the APK to the attic for you by
the play store you don't have to do
anything literally affects one of those
who would be automatically yes it's
automatic nothing he only only starting
your only starting to jelly bean the
order in the funeral we can expect some
compatibility for work only on jelly
bean okay so this will be really done
automatically or in the future old
application from data that application
will disappear at the top state that is
bringing a little glitch at can even me
awesome yes yes yeah so is mean that in
the future all the application will be
encrypted to automatically hey I hate
applications
okay thank these people poor people
upgrade to jellybean omelette funky
there's nothing for you to do if you're
interested in how it works but it read
an interesting hair down I guess look
like looking at how the service works
under the hood which is on nicolet Ellen
coughs blog if you go to any el en k OV
volcom there's an interesting assessment
of the service for your background but
as a developer there's nothing to do any
of the questions from people in the
Hangout before we jump into the pre
submitted questions yeah I might have
one Kathleen them trying to support our
rainy days to the new maps api but the
biggest trouble is animating the layer
the previous AAP i could just draw
something but now it's all ground
overlays or whatever it seems to be no a
good way to animate you start switching
the layers of course so I don't expect a
really unanswerable I'd like what sorry
from point to point so I met marker no I
have a child my application show it
shows the rain radar image okay so it
steps to the time from like 10 minutes
in steps of 10 minutes so that layer
itself is animated and project it on the
map but in so in in the p2 I just have
fun overlay that I animate myself using
a handler and those kinds of things but
in the new API you have to actually add
some ground overlay or child sets or
those kind of things there's no way
about amazing that it has no really no
good way if i try to be set it feasible
or height one layer and then make
another layer visible then it's not
really smooth
interesting no I've not tried that yeah
I thought about just look drawing over
with a few or something but I guess that
won't work writer I'm sure a number of
solutions will emerge over the next
couple of months if it is an issue but I
haven't seen it myself okay yeah you did
I keep put it in a frame layout and just
draw have it your own layer on top of
the map yeah I thought about it but then
i would also need a custom location over
low for that planning events and so
forth yeah yeah and for now for example
now I have an option to share location
on top of the cloud so if it's very
cloudy then you can see your location
still and but yeah if I go dead rat and
I have to draw basically every nothing
like in case you in my show at night oh
yeah try that what part of the letters
are questions so what's that question
from it so also complete text you back
by casa lo de I think you might be muted
Eddie I do you want to unmute and ask
the question yourself hello hi hi how's
it going I posted a question last
weekend or last hangout and I wasn't
able to join because I guess that group
was full what I'm trying to accomplish
is basically have a a multi autocomplete
view back by a cursor loader but what I
want to have happen is have a custom
tokenizer so instead of having like a
comma delimited tokenizer I wanted to
achieve something like a space delimited
tokenizer so I know I have to override
the hook I think it's the token you are
in a text watcher class text watcher was
a on text change method and I'm running
into issues
as far as overriding that because for
example let's say I type in let's say I
type in the word Joe Johnson or the two
words Joe Johnson I think the call to on
text change happens more times than I'm
anticipating when basically a delimiter
was entered like a space I expect it to
only be called once but it's being
called like more than once ok so I'm not
able to successfully implement this
custom on a custom what's it called like
a custom text watcher but if I go take
the approach of like using a simple
cursor adapter and don't go the cursor
loader approach then I'm able to
implement it but it's not I don't think
it's like as efficient so what stage you
trying what how come you can do it with
me cuz their deaths of an overloaded so
I think it has I think it has something
to do with when when I did go with a
simple cursor adapter approach then I
took a look at I have a filter query
provider that has a run query method
that I'm overriding and I'm also
noticing that aunt exchanged method this
run query seems to be getting called
twice as well so I'm not really familiar
with how the text watcher run query
method gets called I was expecting to
just be called once when Texas change I
thought it would just get called once
but it seems like it's getting called
more than once and there's an argument
in the on text change method called s
car sequence it's of type car sequence
and that's basically the length of the
string so the first time on Tex change
is called its of a certain length
and then the second time it's called
it's a different Lane so if I'm trying
to do any kind of processing of a custom
tokenizer it's not what I anticipate all
right it's cold isn't the before text
change call him one afterwards is the
untitled fortune yeah so I try to put
some kind of logic to see what the
string was before exchange and after two
exchanged I was never able to get
something to really work as far as the
changing from from the first call to the
second call so I was looking into that
approach but haven't I haven't come up
with any clean solutions No so you're
not setting the text at any point in
these methods are you like if you're
running it through recognizer then
stripping out spaces or one characters
and then no well basically what i would
wanting to do is as soon as i saw a
delimiter i save this value of s and
then i do something with that value of s
but the problem is this on text change
gets called twice once instead of just
being called once after you see a
delimiter gets called twice so the first
time i see the delimiter it says oh that
the string is Joe Johnson then the
second time it sees actually more text
if I like keep typing and instead of
being that new word it has the entire
string of Joe Johnson plus the extra
text nothing that's the expected
behavior but it takes what she will
always return the entire text as the
Indian suitable text so is there any way
to get as soon as you see a good
delimiter then grab that first the text
before the first delimiter and then
basically only see delimited by
potential donors the thing that's tricky
is that the deliverer is a space that I
want it use but there could be spaces
within a text basically it the
text could be like contacts where you
have a first name and a last name
separated by a space but if you have a
if this multi complete auto or multi
auto complete text view has different
contacts it could have a bunch of
different contact names and within this
contact names it has a first name and a
last name that happens to have a space
so that's where it's becomes a little
tricky with just a comma delimiter it
sounds that you're gonna have to keep
track via yourself ready yeah yeah asian
decide when you want to keep the string
when you don't want to keep it I think
that's now that because if it sounds at
some point you're putting set text
within your tex culture which is
entirely adjustment you can do that but
you need to handle the case either and
if it somehow recursively anything yeah
i had was if you had a tech to where you
could only enter it valid information
which then affected other fields which
that are you affected that one if you
start getting really kind of messy traps
you have to make sure you get to make me
you you account for that basically the
other thing you could take a look at is
the chips UI which is the uo e use in
the SMS application on Android yoga
similarly eight that which is open
source so you can take a look look for
the chips you are i think it's called
which gives you those who know as you
enter a name it turns it into a little
yeah i was reading a little bit about
that but i didn't get to check out the
documentation yet it's what about Oh
somewhere isn't that I'm sure I've seen
it come up a couple of times someone but
yeah I was thinking maybe potentially my
approach once I um see a delimited like
let's say someone typed in Joe Johnson
and then they press space then I can
save this in some other eat a variable
like global variable and regardless of
the what the on text changes then I just
update that global variable and I can
put some arbitrary delimiter within this
string so i could say Joe Johnson and
then put like a pipe that would just
eliminate
in this arbitrary string and then if
more Texas is added on Tex change will
always show what's in the edit text view
right but my global string will show how
its delimited yeah that sounds
reasonable you like hugging them in a
map or sex or something yeah yeah I'm
like that ok and I'll take a look at
that on the chips you I are the chips
and then yeah geyser yeah thank you no
ways but just go back to questions so
what are we trying to make it to a
loader rather than using a on query um
because I wanted to basically do a
synchronous asynchronous Leon do the
loading the background and cursor
loaders are of red that crystal odors
are a lot more efficient at that instead
of like blocking main UI I thought yeah
how to approach this a lot of the
heaviness thing doesn't it and what's
the most complete sexy will do that
anyway for you right you normally use a
cool it's nice in query anyways then
image victims yeah it was cool oh yeah I
think you know me did in religious it
exocrine city anyway so you know I'm all
typed it already does it mean seriously
yeah okay so potentially just using a
simple cursor adapter um I I get it says
efficient as it needs to be because with
the symbol cursor adapter I'm I think
what happened is something about like I
needed to manage the cursor and it
wasn't closed properly that's why I went
with the cursor loader so handled that I
the cursor and managing that efficiently
I think I turned on like a debugging
mode one of the strict modes and it
complained because Herschel the cursor
wasn't closed correctly so that's why
went with approach of cursor loader that
would manage that cursor ya know you did
this done at least Casey sees Mason
query handler with them with a nautical
protects you right is that what you're
doing yeah yeah a scene query handler
went off the ICA you're okay then okay
and then I just have to figure out where
to close that cursor yeah it's my J
Sofia okay all right thank you noise
cool ok cousin chat going on inside bar
mr. Hugo depends okay about the animated
maps questions still crawl difficult
there any more live questions from the
people in the room works here we're just
joined by a couple of people we've got
AJ I think a day and some usual suspects
long enough questions you guys have any
questions relating arv bur from the
netherlands almost certainly be from the
dutch android usergroup i bet it's a
silly anyone have that can be anyone it
does start with will it ever be possible
though it's not really a question we
should be answering in this form but
will it ever be possible to remotely
debug the android application running on
a device for a painting a cable just an
interesting question ocm Google TV
devices already allowing us but Android
devices in general done there's a few
ways if you've got a rooted device you
can do it mr. atb to listen on port
instead connect through wirelessly I've
seen people doing it but I've not heard
anything about no future announcements
etc etc etc yeah I think you can put it
in TCP mode right whenever at your phone
connected through USB once then you can
remote do with it
this is the main look up to come on that
is something like a DB TCP or something
right yeah and then you can connect to
it the same way as you connect to people
because there's no UI for getting IP
address back out of it again well you
can look at the wireless setting like
like you doing with Google TV so with
the way through google TV side of it
works you have to enter in the IP
address of the machine you're going to
connect to do and then from your machine
APB connect with your pious the device
and then from that point you kind of
creative a pairing process then you can
do it and then it just looks like a USB
device essentially but yeah generally I
think most developers are happy
connecting cables is new yeah and the
thing is that you have to first put it
in TC Piedmont with a cable so if you
are able to do that then you probably
just want to stick the game with yeah
I'm still pretty sure it's only
available if you're rooted device right
yeah I thank you remember seeing it at
some point Farah not the raft or
something does yeah you can only set
your device into TV mode if you are lose
it really yeah I'm just trying to find
it myself now but oh it's a question on
Stack Overflow the seminal stack
overflow got an answer which doesn't
require root yes not the question number
is easiest place it I just better do
it's a long number cool
in the gfs comments Carlos asks has
questioned about moderators indoor deaf
community can you ask Allah to give some
more details about what you think
there's not enough moderation going on
in the Android f community or you're
enjoying it or what's going on yeah cuz
more details please that answer that
door say if your device is ridic you go
at the top yeah but the second paragraph
form a computer if you're at USB expose
already that part just works i'm pretty
sure i did that i was i borrowed some
phones from a colleague and then I'm
gave him Beckett's phone that's still
vivo x cool I can try right now on its
Jamie habar says I need to share a class
worth of android screens with a teacher
and so on put me in the right direction
okay now i can access the output on a pc
with usb but i need this over wireless
so teach you can view what is going on
in their class so it gets you find the
works i'm going to avoid a screen share
so i'm going to say that the basically
that sounds to be some like miracast
which is over egg you're going to have a
nexus vorti working on board which i
don't have any on the market just yet
and in the stations use loads of hdmi
broadcasters if you H do I owe you a
little opposite you either take too much
with you right VNC not less right
someone maybe then he goes one way you
can view desktop tablet not vice versa
yeah what doesn't make a droid can you
do need education there's droid at
screen or so not that say oh you say see
you've already managed to get it from
onto a pc / USB and then can you share
from the pc to your teachers i'm out
perhaps but yeah be ideal weight with
you and I think this is to make sure
that all the kids are doing what the
told maybe because it sounds like each
kids got their own android device and
then the teachers want to make sure what
they're doing is right even then more
problem between them
password language do is kind of like
Altoids style but you get all the
devices coming up with all the
screenshots yeah you need something
custom phone was worked that properly
yeah for the teacher to be able to
choose which one of the screen she was
looking at all to go more than that
screen the light as the definitely
against our security model Jen kissed
him on there and here's an interesting
question firmer gabrielle in earning us
and he has a view pager with multiple
pages with multiple list views in each
of the pages at the moment each list
fragment and it screwing different parts
of the same database table and at the
moment each fragment queries the has its
own curse later querying the database
and he's wondering if it would be more
efficient to have one query again to
that table at the activity level and
then farm out that information to the
different fragments a new information
well databases are inherently secured
against asynchronous queries on name
what about classes because if then not
then I could imagine you two get into
some sticky situations where if you're
flicking between the two and both
adapters make that off the same cursor
then it could lock mm-hmm so it might
actually be safe to do it the way you're
doing it because then you have
independent curses so we need a bit more
for my depends how much data we're
talking about here if he's talking about
my 510 K update whatever their fair
enough maybe load that into the activity
and just use it inside the application
if you load it without the application
suffering and without being concerned
about memory but if he's talking about
much more data then potentially you
could load the first level of all the
data for the list and then when you
drill down load that separately well I
guess as well if you've got a view pager
in your recycling the list fragments as
you're swiping then you could load other
the dates you need that one fragment
then as it gets light doesn't kill you
kill the data with a view pager when
right thing there is nothing there was
version where you can make it to a come
here no you lose them kill them yeah it
sounds like depending on how you put
your view pager set up and the amount of
data but it may be a good idea but we
just give a little bit more information
yeah everything else in the stream my
worry is that the whole point of like
he's in curses so it's it can be looking
up charity you know list you could have
not you know grow to know very large
data set work and I worry about the
overhead of like trying to manage that
all yourself and piece it back together
are you returning much larger data to
him I think the idea that you know I
don't there is a right answer here I
think I leave it you could probably end
up writing a lot more code it might be a
little bit more efficient but then the
overhead of having to do it all yourself
might not be worth it say you could do a
test and see what which if it works out
anybody month yeah for me it's just a
little bit more information but yeah I
can't agree if you're managing all that
yourself it there's a lot of room or I
think things could start just leaking in
eaters and bad times and he Carlos was
replied to his original question oh yeah
okay Carla says may problem with the
introduc community in saying is this
coil of advertising join with different
levels of Android questions and so on
maybe different sections for different
levels of QA of our Android so we have
different and sub-forums in there right
what are they I remember on that you
guys donate one question so for this
house is put on the android community no
restrictions and yeah so there are sub
section right so yeah there are sub
section on that if you think we need
some more than we be happy to work for
more if needs be and yeah the moment I
think the communities are all settling
down I think there's a bit of a
community's rush at the moment with
everyone trying to get everyone to join
each other's communities a lot of
cross-pollination I think we haven't
mean we've had quite a light hand we've
tried not to moderate too hard
only things which are completely off
topic if there's you know some overlaps
on saying you know join our design and
developers community or so now that you
know which is bad for some people have
been trying not to remove those kind of
posts but it sounds like you feel that
we could do some more some more
moderation so that's good could come
back good feedback so say when I was
sitting in the hay out here have any
feedback you've been using the Android
developer community if you found it
useful we found it too noisy is anyone
else got any experience to ensure oh no
you mean our local community the G+
community there's a lot of noise from
people I want to make an upgrade to a
start I wouldn't I want to make it looks
like a lot of fish is like I want to
make an app where do I start and then
yeah some point to android com but let's
you're so obvious to me that you think
we can do like a newbie's section or
different community organized yeah
something like that just maybe if you
have some points on place to put a
frequently asked questions or starting
points of because most of the responses
on those kinds of questions are pointing
to developers com flash of energy to the
developer side stretch training right
right the right place to start i guess
but there are a lot of those kinds of
quest and also a lot of questions that
are don't make sense in whatever way i
think the problem is it so quite quite
large topic isn't an Android development
they mean that yeah hundreds a huge
range from New be questions to
incredibly advanced questions I feel
like a good level of discourse in the
Android design community is being less
noisy I think because it's a smaller
focus it's a smaller subset that's
motoring maybe that's what's missing I
mean we have this sub-forums but you
ought to get you know if you follow if
you're in the community see all of the
thing that I public up so it kinda feel
nausea that's we need to have other
communities or something I don't know if
that's what that's feedback we need to
take back and work out best way forward
but splitting up to check out my app or
services it's a good thing
yeah I really like that idea of being
able to broadcast potentially what
you're working on and letting other
people know oh this is what I've worked
on so far check it out it would give
some feedback pretty cool for like sort
of early testing beta testers yeah good
community and get feedback I feel like
it's kind of difficult to really
categorize um where posts can land
because you never really know there
could be a really advanced user posting
on the community and then some more some
novice a developer so it's it's hard to
just say Oh post directly to this sub
community because there will be over
that there will be overlap yeah but I
guess you're always going to have that
they're always need to be that entry
point and then people are going to be
pointing off to the right thing and
there will be people that will just find
the new kind of like if there was a new
sort of community people would just jump
straight in there personally find post
in the sun morn just go actually you're
probably better off than that in the
main community so wait it out yeah I
think if there is maybe the first time
you actually join the community um I
think it may be like intimidating for
some new person to go and see oh this is
where I enter any type of discussion if
maybe the very first time you see you
join the community it says if you are
sort of a novice user we suggest going
and posting in this sub-forum yeah we
switch pin vise that you see in the IRC
channels back in the day when anto is
fairly new you kind of have google
engineers versus other people and yeah
you'd have people come in and they did
she just ask product questions then it's
in it's like go here so yeah I guess you
need that level of direction or my other
bill yeah good feedback and really
sidebars commenting it's very noisy lots
of a look at my appt post to rather than
every community post appearing in my
timeline I would maybe only like to see
those people in list from people in my
circle
the order to view all posts I need to
visit the community page so if I like
the volume sliders you can have on
circle right I don't get community
person went online I get them for their
kind of gently snuck in quality my dear
that helps nobody getting loose about
you mine why runner th is just as 99
plus any messages these little things
like Carlos is suggesting that maybe we
could have some help us with a moderator
badge tell things that create easier
yeah I guess it kind of takes on a bit
before I'm moderate to style approach
yeah just have noticed there's no
relevant does anyone else have any
questions like I'm ticket I think so it
is following link to step over location
which I'm instantly regretting Michael
check on sea lochs mean orientation of a
dream service so Michaelis be fiddling
with the dream service API Michaels in
the hell right can you ask the question
life rather than having us figure out
who we just never get away what's the
first top of the top sorry
my bad I'm just watching the ice cream
are we gonna freezing it you don't even
know enough English to live yes and not
alive dude people are still watching us
we're in a window somehow hello so we
thought okay he left the Hangout just
open the live stream and realized I can
still see myself so there must have been
a window open somewhere let's not click
through to links to gay and not going to
be there are my questions you have to
type it out I voiceover literally so
it's michael in the hang out with us
there yeah yeah raise it to Michael do
you have a camera on my phone I'm
guessing that I'm guessing the same
Mikey's messed-up story again in this
day and age excellent should we get for
another moderator question are the
reigning more moderate questions i've
had i've got the actual Stack Overflow
Dennis not a chance since we've done a
few okay so we'll worry about Michaels
question from stucco play so he's been
playing with the dream service API and
like to lock the screen orientation to
landscape when the dream service is
shown
because eee shown widescreen photos and
doesn't want to have black bars he's
tried number things like set orientation
and using android screen orientation
landscape in the manifest but none of
worked sniffing wonder is it possible to
lock the orientation of a dream service
see let's try this ah not since the API
work public previously so yeah
differentially juntos isn't quite an
activity similar to an activity but not
actually an activity I'm wondering if
you can get the window manager and ask
the window managers to do some stuff for
you that because I could we're doing it
there's an unattached window so the
answer is we don't know offhand I'm just
thinking out loud I mean no I would make
sense though she defined as a a window
feature all of the current ones of our
landscape or portrait write in the
comments Andrea Kelly suggesting you
could use a different crop tight scale
type in your image views as you don't
have that bars yeah I think the solution
would be to make it support for try to
be honest but yeah instead of just
landscape people may want to have it
either way around and all the current
dreams to support both I just make sure
of the currents current dream supports
both yeah
I mean that might be the opportunity
files have multiple images rather than
just the one and basically I tried to
mess with the window manager yeah use
another moment but the result is only
show full extent of the image the scale
type so here maybe try doing something
nice with multiple ages and animating
around when you change but really please
just try and support both orientations
may I mean my dock for nexus 4 could be
port rating from a nexus 7 or 10 would
be landscape and if I want to choose
your dream on both one of them wouldn't
be incremental yeah so be nice if you
just supported both let the user choose
which way around they want their device
and you Kelly suggesting Ken Burns
effect I like it it can outside the box
okay is there anything the moderator you
can see ya so hundra's listing that
Billings and support subscriptions are
you working on it we're not going
outside of it but that sounds like the
safe assumption again from Andrew Kelly
the one-man moderating machine you ask
in response to LVL and piracy question
last week it wasn't it mentioned at
Google i/o that future done is in place
there will be signed with I specifics if
it's tificate their way making a
tentative device so that's correct let's
see encryption that we talked about
earlier which is heavy question I had
the dream cells question GE asks is
there a way to work out the measured
height and width of a text with an eye
patch before it's drawn I've tried
getting the image height working padding
and then the length and hyper text using
paint it's close but still a bit off so
if i was going to interpret the question
correctly you're trying to get the
measured height overview it sounds like
you're trying to get it before it
actually midget so this heretic approach
i would say is rather than find imitate
what the layout system is doing is
waiting to actually be measured and then
get it so if you look at stein called
the view tree observer class and you can
get a b-tree observer
you're currently connectivity and
attached to like the on global layout I
think that's negative n so you can get a
call back once lay out you know once
it's done the layer laying out a
measuring part of your application so at
that point once the measuring is
completed you can then query of you to
get the pixel size and wants it to be
major touch they do that rather than
trying to imitate the layout system good
call then that one's on older than that
one cool Andrew Kelly asks when creating
entries in the devices Conda done
directly rather than launching in 10 is
there a way to include HTML links or
image attachments I don't know me not to
the extras you can put and so my gut
feeling is I think you only have access
to the kind of like notes feel which
case you can put any tags I don't think
actually mark it up anyway don't you
believe won't if you slept like a link
in that I haven't tried it assume andrew
has tried it he's typing now so he's not
much of one diretion any markup i supply
just gets rendered as text nothing was a
contradiction to allow girls also face
and I don't try to add have time to look
at convocation work out what it is if
you're getting access to the content
provider to put the entries into the
Canada stuff if you could get access to
another calendar entry in the concept
writer then maybe you could find out
what the official one does yeah creator
then through the web UI or something but
i think in it and see how it gets saved
it could be interesting that's obviously
depending whether you can get access to
it from the Android side road trip to ya
in which you gave to do them yeah I'm
all looking oh look at the source code
offender
she left yeah again because then you
should be out see what the intent does
that's why would it yeah check the
suicide like to create a link to really
launch an app when clicked from a
calendar entry hmm no yeah I think you
can do that I think that's what Mike did
right when they really did it I guess
that's getting it to launch in a premier
or you could do it's just yet another
cases of them ya hala Madrid says
oginski better API for official
functionality for gaming apps that then
falls into the not commenting on future
product announcements so sorry it up oh
that's what he did read ahead yes you
don't think I was picked around with men
in the country city friends and since
we're running out of time we'll give her
the people live in the in the Hangout at
last final chance to ask any any
questions you guys but I think I chose
yeah ask add or say goodbye or yeah I
but oh good go hate arsenal yeah I had a
question about how to set up the
miracast the sport is there a certain
app and you need to download or is just
you need an adapter on a TV in it I play
things it's under the display setting
right yeah under display you just how
much was it lays on and then it appears
on your quick settings menu the
two-finger Drago especially the one
thing yes if you go to displays and your
settings at fairs last options as
wireless display what's okay once it's
on then you should get an option and in
the quick settings menu okay nothing
i'll take the very display some internal
if there are you just connect your off
and good to go there goes why this is
why this is but nice and i can't wait to
get myself a dongle and try it out
hopefully um we'll have a lot more on
the market in q1 next yet TN different
companies yes he
yeah I was laptop that has wideout
capabilities but I'm not able to detect
the laptop as far as a wireless display
no okay miracast and why do I over do
two different standards oh it's a little
bit different they're probably both
transmitting device is not receiving
devices all right any to yes and a
laptop is not a receiving device right
you can't just broadcast with a dental
sony can't see laptops key or anything I
don't think will be quite fun that
repeater look anyway all right guys I
think we'll call it to a close there it
is come free yeah well happy holidays I
said this is the last one this year most
will be back in the New Year some height
I all them out too wet and but yeah
thank you very much and have a good
break yes guys